hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game between Earth and space and
if you're wondering why Earth is playing
a game of chess with spaces because
today is the 50th anniversary of the
first ever game played between Earth and
space and the crew of Soyuz 9 played
against ground control and the game
ended in well I'm not gonna spoil it for
you in case you haven't seen it but the
game did end
now here the honor of defending earth he
goes to Sergei Carter conformable chess
championship Challenger as he does it
doesn't really need any introduction and
he will be playing against the
cosmonauts anatoly ivanishin and even
wagner now these guys are some 400
kilometers above the earth on the
International Space Station which
recently welcomed NASA astronauts Bob
Behnken and Doug Hurley under SpaceX
spacecraft while Sergei is playing from
the Moscow Museum of cosmonautics and
all this exactly 50 years after the
first game space versus earth now I will
link an article from chess 24 regarding
this match this would have just talked
to you about this from the article in
there you can check out also this game
the first ever game played you can also
check out this game being played live
it's really awesome with commentary from
a grandmaster again emitters mischenko
so do check it out it will be the first
thing you see in the description below
and here are these gentlemen even
Incheon and Wagner there we can see
they're playing like this they have a
tablet and they're of course playing
using a tablet so you have to be careful
that it doesn't float away and Sergey is
playing using a normal board and someone
else of course is transmitting the moves
now if you think you know how this game
is gonna go
you have no idea this is one one crazy
game so without further ado let's check
it out the cosmonauts get the white
pieces as they did in the first ever
game 50 years ago and they opened with
e4 but in the first game they opened
with the d4 so let's see what what
Carter Kane has in store for them he
replies with E 5 we have Knight to f3
Knight to c6 and Bishop to b5 so the
real opus is on the board we have a 6
morph is the
fans and here we have Bishop captures
they go for the exchange variation D
captures on c6 and here they just Castle
and Sergei goes for Bishop to e6 he
offers the e5 pawn but it's not really
offered since after captures you can
just go Queen d4 and after the knight
moves you you win back your pawn by by
grabbing the e4 pawn so after Bishop to
e6 with b3 a very rare continuation and
keratin continues with c5 now here
obviously you cannot capture the e5 pawn
because Queen here will attack both the
knight and the rook on a1 and there is
one given the in the database where d3
was played but here however the Cosmo
nuts actually do go for Knight captures
on e5 and here we reach the position
from the thumbnail or you know I might
not put it in the thumbnail but I
probably will
so here in Knight captures any 5 and so
get pretty much instantly played Queen
to d4 is now both the knight and the
rocker under attack so now if you move
the knight you lose the rook if you save
the rook somehow by playing c3 or Knight
to c3 you lose the night but here they
gonna Knight to c4 and it's it's very
interesting because if Sarah goes for
the rook with Queen captures on a1 then
Bishop to b2 only move that doesn't lose
the Queen nice Queen captures on a2 and
then Knight the c3 traps the Queen all
of these squares are covered by the
Knights and this is a 1 square is
covered by the bishop so the queen is
lost so here you would probably have to
go for Bishop captures on c4 why grabs
the Queen Bishop captures on f1 King
captures and you end up with this
position where White has a queen and as
compensation Black has two rooks but
with the King still being in the center
of the board and none of the pieces are
a pieces are developed the white should
be better here so instead a Kraken goes
for Bishop captures on c4 he eliminates
one of the nights so now you are of
course ready to capture the rook and now
pretty much everyone would expect c3 and
after the Queen moves only then do you
win back your piece but this isn't what
happens here after Bishop captures on c4
the Cosmo not actually played be
captures on c4 and they sacrifice an
entire rook
which kirkin goes for we have Queen
captures on a1 and now Knight to c3 now
the queen is trapped however you don't
lose the Queen as since there isn't you
don't have a way of attacking the Queen
but the Queen has no squares so it's
it's a light Black is down a queen but
but not really so here Kerrigan goes for
the immediate b5 saying I want to play I
want to play b4 dislodge your knight and
then bring my queen back into the game
bihter going to let the Queen e5 Queen
f6 or maybe even just by grabbing dat
pawn
however Queen to h5 here moving the
Queen away from the first rank and now
preparing Bishop to a 3 which will
indeed win the Queen so here our
character doesn't really have all that
much to do about it if before just
getting the night away then still Bishop
to a3 will win the Queen so instead he
was for Knight to f6 he attacks whites
Queen we have Queen back to f3 if Queen
to e5 check King d8 is very strong then
the bishop can come to d6 the rotate can
come to d8 and black will have a very
nice development so Queen back to f3
instead and only now before saying now
you either move the knight or you you
trap my queen but they go for a 5 and
they just this is a you know these guys
are no reverse gear cosmonauts they're
just you know everything is moving
forward now the rook is under attack the
knight is under attack and also well
just the Bishop t3 will be the threat of
winning the Queen so Syria it has to do
something about this he just castles
here and it's quite the idea I don't
think I've mentioned but the time format
here is it's sort of a classical game
since it's a 45 minutes each I don't
know if there's increment I don't think
they've mentioned it if any of you do
know do show in the comments so all of
us can learn but here okay if you go for
this captures then black and just
capture here and then you no longer trap
the Queen because you can just get away
from the Queen but still quinta a a to
check will pose a lot of problems for
the black king you don't maybe you don't
have anything with white but you
probably do have a perpetual so here
after
inside castles Bishop to e3 now
everything is hanging and well what do
you do here
of course Queen captures on f1 you do
not allow real captures Queen so at
least you grab the rook with check King
captures on f1 and now B captures on c3
eliminating the knight here we have e
captures on f6 and now C captures on b2
other than this if you don't go for this
with the threat of d1 Queen White is
just better there's no way around this
so I Sergei has to go for it seek after
sandy - now he's threatening d1 which
would bring another Queen in terror game
and of course black would be much better
here so white has to go for Quinta a8
with check we have came to d7 and now
Queen to d5 with check so what do you do
here you either go back or you go back
well obviously or you block with the
bishop but the Bishop to d6 is very
dangerous for example if Bishop to d6
then you get F captures and g7 attacking
this rook and after the rook moves let's
say rook goes over here then Bishop here
and now everything is nicely defended
white also has a very strong pass pawn
on g7 yes you still have two looks
against the Queen but this point is
gonna fall and white white will be much
better here with the bishop and Queen
against two rooks with the black King so
wide open
so here Kerrigan has no other option but
to go back King to c8 and the cosmonauts
repeat Queen to a eight with check King
to d7 Queen to d5 check King th now Cara
can still not ready to agree to a draw
but now Queen to e4 with Czech and here
you don't have you don't have a move
Bishop to e7 Queen just captures this
checkmate so you can't even offer some
material to keep the game going
so King back to d7 and it was in this
position that Sergei Cara can offer the
draw and the cosmonauts will accept the
draw as they also don't have a way of
pushing for more than a draw here so if
you're like me you're probably wondering
what just happened here like how strong
are these guys they just you know
casually play a game again
the former World Chess Championship
Challenger you know sacrificed
everything and he barely escapes with a
draw
I mean how strong how strong are these
guys
or I mean I do imagine they have some
free time up there but IIIi didn't think
they'd be playing so much chess so
really impressive game bye bye bye the
three of them I mean it was very very
impressive if you want I do recommend
you check out the link in the
description below and do check out the
original footage as it's just it's just
awesome yeah I mean and the game is so
great everything is just moves forward
there's no going back it's it's what we
all enjoy in chess so that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it so the result a
space to earth remains a tie the first
match 50 years ago ended in a or now
I've messed it up I thought I'm not
gonna tell you how it ended as maybe you
guys want to check it out but I messed
up but yeah the first match ended in a
draw and this one also ended in a draw
so we do have time to prepare for 2070
and then maybe either earth or space can
can grab a lead so once again I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank von
wenk
Paul Runge tobias Rath Stone music and
the Jody Paulette for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check too
on my previous videos thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of everything
we're covering checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the world or you know outside
of it so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day